Harrison Bader is the anomaly not the
preview when we were raised we did
everything we played everything now
everything's specialized specialized
well that's cuz all these parents are
[__] out of their mind and think
their kids are going to be Pros I mean
these parents are so [__] delusional
I was at this Central Park baseball game
a couple years ago where like these two
dads were just getting out of my I
finally just like I can get loud I'm
like friends nobody at this park is
playing Major League Baseball like this
is all funny games but do you understand
what's going on in central South America
right now like every kid is our kid's
age three times the size and throwing 90
M an hour there's no soft kid in
Manhattan going to the league Harrison
Bader is the anomaly not the preview